[Music]
hi everyone i'm alison wagenfeld with
google cloud welcome to google cloud
next and thank you to our google
orchestra composed of bay area googlers
we are coming to you live from our
google cloud campus in silicon valley
where i'm here with sundar pichai and
thomas curion
we have an incredible lineup over the
next three days with live keynotes demos
and q a with our leadership and over 140
sessions covering all our cloud
solutions
our customers and partners will share
how they're using google cloud in google
workspace technology to tackle their
greatest challenges and opportunities
we are humbled to support their work and
share their stories
thank you for being here with us
and now please join me in welcoming
google and alphabet ceo sundar pachai
hi everyone
welcome to google cloud next
2021
we are happy you're here
of course i'd be happier if he could
actually be here in person
don't get me wrong thomas is great
company
but he still doesn't laugh at my
container jokes
so while many of us are still waiting
for a return to normal it does feel like
we are on our way
the question is will we recognize normal
when we get there
the pandemic has sped up digitization in
all aspects of our lives
it's changed how we visit a doctor
how our kids learn in school
and how we connect with one another
and it's made the future of work our
present
giving us renewed opportunity to
transform our organizations
from our work with customers
thomas and i have learned there are
three things that position us
to be most helpful to businesses
first our cloud platform
it's designed to help enterprises
transform through digitization
built on the deep investments we've made
in technical infrastructure over the
past 23 years
looking at our networking and data
center investments alone
we have the largest network with the
lowest latency of any cloud provider
with our expansions into warsaw delhi
melbourne and toronto this year we now
have 28 regions
with plans for 10 more
and it's all connected by 19 subsea
cables
a grace hopper transatlantic cable will
be the first to incorporate novel
optical fiber switching
second our enterprise customers benefit
from our consumer scale and innovation
we have a deep and broad consumer
ecosystem of devices and services
youtube connects a global community of
viewers and creators
nest assistant and maps are loved by
people around the world
we have the unique ability to connect
consumer ecosystems with enterprise
ecosystems
for example the realistic voices and
language understanding that powers
google assistant
can improve enterprise customer
experiences and increase satisfaction
and the underlying visual technology
that enables google lens to help people
shop
or learn about a new flower in their
garden
can help manufacturers identify defects
third we offer comprehensive security
that helps organizations including ours
protect what matters security is
foundational to everything we do
we have a long history of building it
into every layer of the computing
environment
we are a pioneer of zero trust computing
and have deep experience running this
model at scale
on its own any one of these pillars
would be helpful to customers
put together they can be transformative
which is the mission of google cloud
we continue to drive innovation through
our products
over the past year we have had more than
1500 product and feature releases
that's about four a day
they're all designed to be helpful
from smart canvas in google workspace
that makes collaboration richer
to new ai powered industry solutions
and bigquery omni for data analytics
across any cloud
we've also made significant partnership
announcements
for example we teamed up with global
telecom leaders such as ericsson
nokia and t-systems to deliver 5g edge
and hosted computing solutions
what i'm most excited about is how our
strengths in cloud
consumer and security are helping top
enterprises
accelerate their transformation
ford chose google as their
transformation partner
because of our strength in consumer
and cloud
together we are innovating in
electrification
connectivity and self-driving
technologies
ford is harnessing google maps to help
drivers navigate
google assistant to help drivers
concentrate
on google play to keep passengers
learning and entertain
l'oreal partnered across google to build
a virtual try on experience
they are harnessing the best ai models
as well as using youtube to build a
community of fans
and google shopping to make it easy to
discover and buy their products
we are humble that so many organizations
continue to put their trust in google
cloud
and we are committed to helping you
solve the biggest challenges you face
i'll be back a little later to talk more
about how we do that
but first i'll turn the stage over to
thomas korean ceo of google cloud to
talk more about our mission
thank you sundar
hello everyone
it's a pleasure to be here on google's
silicon valley campus
today for the moment we all look forward
to all year long
the opportunity to connect with you
our customers partners and developers
and to share all the amazing exciting
stuff we've been working on
a special thank you to all our sponsors
especially our luminary sponsors
accenture atos maven wave and deloitte
let's first hear from some of our
customers about the amazing ways in
which they have accelerated
transformation with google cloud
[Music]
the pandemic really did accelerate the
digital wave of change by easily three
to five years
[Music]
we transitioned to all virtual care
we're better positioned to accelerate
fast forward to today we have a truly
profound permanent structural
transformation now our team can look at
hundreds of calls in minutes instead of
weeks
our business has really been transformed
with the help of google cloud we have
spikes in demand we can scale four times
in less than five minutes
schrodinger is transforming the way
scientists are developing drugs chemical
space is almost infinite we can do
things we couldn't do before can't i
just track my shipment we think that we
can help solve that for the supply chain
how can we help workers with artificial
intelligence suddenly lots of ideas
become interesting we're very excited to
develop our artificial intelligence and
machine learning access to innovation
the speed of innovation seconds
milliseconds all matter rethinking
routine and pioneering simplicity the
partnership with google cloud provides
us with technology that will drive us to
be better
[Music]
now it's not a secret that many of the
biggest and most innovative technology
companies
leaders such as spotify twitter shopify
mikado libre sharechat dapper labs and
so many other exciting startups and tech
leaders
choose google cloud to help them build
scale and innovate
still other customers are transforming
using our purpose-built industry
solutions
the home depot for instance use contact
center ai to reduce customer resolution
time by 91 million minutes
procter gamble creates personalized
omni-channel journeys from over
275 million consumer records
ikea retail used recommendations ai to
increase e-commerce click-through rates
by 30 percent
and increase order value by 2 percent
fih a foxconn company
used visual inspection to identify
defects
10 times more accurately
mr cooper a leading mortgage services
provider
use document ai to process mortgage
documents
400 percent more efficiently
and bank of new york mellon
developed a liquidity solution that
predicts nearly 40 percent of security
settlement failures with 90 percent
accuracy
we're helping many businesses drive
durable innovation through long-term
partnerships with google's
transformation cloud
now to help them transform we focus on
five key themes
one
are we the best at understanding and
using data in an industry
two do we have the industry's leading
technology infrastructure
three are we creating the best hybrid
workplace for our passionate and
talented employees
four
do we know that our data
systems
and users are secure now
and that they will be secure in the
future
and five
are we working together to address the
most important challenges
facing our world today
we help organizations address these
important questions
let's start with the first question
are we the best
at understanding and using data in an
industry
we help organizations unify their data
across multiple clouds and silos
combining structured and unstructured
data and making data every employee's
super power
using data analytics and ai together
schrodinger accelerated clinical drug
discovery by 60
finding new breakthroughs faster
like many states around the united
states the wisconsin department of
workforce development confronted a wave
of new unemployment claims
using google's data cloud they clear
over
750 000 unemployment claims
reducing claim times from weeks to just
days
and dispersing over 2 billion in
unemployment
benefits walmart is transforming the
experience for the approximately 220
million shoppers
around the globe who visit a walmart
store
club or e-commerce website each week
i'm honored today to welcome suresh
kumar
executive vice president
walmart's global chief technology
officer and chief development officer
hi thomas and hello everyone
i'm excited to be here today to share
about how we at walmart are innovating
on behalf of our customers
our associates and the role that our
partners like you google have played in
our innovation journey
now i came to walmart at a time of
incredible digital transformation and
jointly with my team
created a robust execution plan to
accelerate the transformation across
three areas
building great customer experiences
optimizing our business and modernizing
our platform and our infrastructure
each of these three priorities are
individually important but when you
bring them together at the scale of a
business like walmart it has a massive
impact if you move with speed
you can completely transform global
operations and disrupt entire industries
some of our most data intensive or
critical decisioning process
are getting the big query treatment
through this not only are we seeing
significant savings that will continue
as we migrate more and more data over we
are also seeing the ability to use the
data in interesting ways
including enabling analytics at scale
and turning data into actionable
insights from a data migration to
bigquery
standpoint
97 of the tables used for data vectors
have already migrated to the cloud
and 30 of the big data have been
migrated
with plans to almost double that by the
end of this fiscal year
and the cherry on the top
is that bigquery has allowed us to
integrate with pretty much any data
visualization tool and analytics tool
that's out there
thereby improving our processing time by
23 percent and of course needless to say
a much better user experience
using bigquery has had a direct impact
on our business
an excellent example is our ability to
close our financial books in three days
instead of five days
and that's a pretty big deal
leveraging our cloud
has enabled us to unleash the potential
of ai across our entire business this
goes from predicting demand to managing
in-stock levels to optimizing supply
chain to freeing up time for our
associates to serve our customers
as one example express delivery which is
our two hour delivery service which we
launched last year
actively uses ai behind the scenes as
the customer is creating that order
multiple algorithms work in eurasian to
optimize the delivery route
and determine if the customer is
eligible for express delivery we are
building our own ai and ml capabilities
to power multiple areas of our business
including
classification natural language
processing forecasting regression
computer vision predictions process
automations and a whole lot more
so to wrap up
i'm really excited about the opportunity
walmart has to drive innovation and to
further disrupt the retail industry
i hope
you will agree that our work together
is making a huge difference
for our customers and our associates
thank you for having me
thank you suresh
you know tens of thousands of incredible
organizations like walmart
choose google's data cloud for four
reasons first google's data cloud is the
most complete and unified data and ai
platform
to help you manage every stage of the
data life cycle
from running operational transactions to
developing analytical applications
we help customers unify data lakes and
warehouses as data lake houses
to reduce complexity
and to combine structured and
unstructured data
built in data science and ai with
support for mapreduce spark and presto
enables continuous learning and
experimentation
and we support real-time streaming
that natively uses open source standards
like beam and flink
google's data cloud is also unmatched
for speed
scale
security and reliability
bigquery one of the most successful and
beloved data warehouse solutions with
its unique serverless approach
during a typical week
helps more than 3 000 different
organizations
analyze more than 200 petabytes of data
and thousands of customers use data proc
to run spark and hadoop clusters easily
spanner a fully managed relational
database with unlimited scale
and multi-zone and multi-region
consistency
serves more than 1
billion requests per second
and provides a 5 9 sla
google data cloud's vertex ai
offers the ai pioneered at google
research and deep mind so that every
data scientist and ml engineer
can now build deploy and scale ai models
faster
and with 80 percent less code
using ai
the same way google does
for instance ge appliances an appliance
manufacturing leader for more than a
century
is using google cloud including ai the
edge to build innovative digital
products
with over-the-air updates
finally
google's data cloud is more open
standards based
you can choose from postgres my sequel
redis mongodb or migrate from oracle or
sql server
and we have strategic partners
with leading data driven applications
for instance c3ai
has made its entire lineup of ai based
applications available on google cloud
our customers can analyze
govern and visualize data from many
databases and storage system on google
or other clouds
including all of google's databases
google sheets
and bigquery
using looker
our premiere bi and embedded analytics
solution
you know today
we're thrilled and excited to announce
that we'll be integrating tableau a
leader in data visualization with looker
google sheets and bigquery
tableau customers will soon be able to
use looker's semantic model
enabling new levels of data governance
and access to data
let's take a look at this alex over to
you
thank you thomas in this demo we're
going to show you how you can seamlessly
use looker and tableau together to
answer your critical business questions
let's say i work at an e-commerce
company and our looker model provides a
consistent view across the organization
for our most important business metrics
here for example you can see the
definition for gross margin
our looker dashboard is based on that
same semantic model since it provides
trusted insights at a glance i can
immediately see that sales are up
however did i miss anything let's find
out
say i'm more comfortable working in
spreadsheets i can now take advantage of
the new integration between looker and
google sheets
with a couple of clicks i have access to
my governed and trusted looker data in
sheets and i can easily connect to my
data models
to understand which factors are
impacting sales i'll drag and drop
fields from my model into a pivot table
to break out sales by category over time
since it's pulling from looker i can
trust that all the data definitions are
consistent i can use familiar sheets
formulas and formatting to get insights
faster and understand how specific
products are selling
we see a notable downward trend month
over month for activewear i want to
share these findings with my marketing
team who's using tableau
now i can use the new tableau and looker
integration to combine data for my
looker data model with marketing data to
build a more comprehensive view of my
business
next i'm going to plot sales by category
and then add marketing spend to the view
tableau makes it easy for me to drill
down on relevant data now i can see that
social marketing spend was significantly
lower for activewear and this is why
there's a downward trend in activewear
sales
i'm going to publish this result on
tableau online and tag my marketing team
so they can take action
leveraging integrations between tableau
sheets and looker allows our teams to
build powerful visualizations using
trusted data we can then share these
visualizations throughout our
organization to drive informed decisions
action and impact back over to you
thomas
thank you alex
the second questions customers ask
do we have industry-leading technology
infrastructure
we're experiencing great momentum with
our open infrastructure cloud many of
the most demanding and technically
advanced customers in the world
disproportionately choose us
take for example leading media companies
and streaming services such as univision
and global the largest media group in
latin america
they use our high performance networking
computing and storage to broadcast media
including live events such as the recent
tokyo olympics leading
telecommunications companies are also
choosing google cloud reliance geo the
world's second largest mobile carrier is
automating its 5g network
vodafone is processing over a billion
network events each day
at t
is delivering new multi-access edge
computing solutions
and telus is migrating critical i t and
network workloads
all to google cloud
you know leading data management
companies including data bricks redis
cockroach labs couch-based elastic
influx data maria db mongodb neo4j and
single store
are all growing faster on google cloud
than on any other cloud
and they love
our storage scalability and advanced
infrastructure
mongodb for instance
has more net new customers
via google cloud marketplace
than on any other cloud
leading cyber security companies such as
palo alto networks exuberant fy shape
splunk broadcom and forgerock
are also choosing google cloud for its
performance global scale and underlying
security
are migrating and transforming
sap
and vmware workloads to google cloud
in just the last year we've added three
times the number of sap customers
as the prior year
and were exhilarating
paypal for instance has an sap hana
scale out system
supporting 40 million business
transactions daily
200 billion records touched in just 30
seconds
mitel in canada
migrated over 1 000
vmware virtual machines in less than 90
days
to google cloud vmware engine
nilas
an api platform company
chose our tile virtual machines
along with google kubernetes engine
as they saw over 40 percent better price
performance than in a competitor
you know customers choose our open cloud
infrastructure for three main reasons
first
we make your path to migrate and
modernize using cloud easy
with migration tools
new serverless and container
capabilities
and managed services
as your developers spend more time
building experiences
that your customers love
second we offer transformative
capabilities with cutting edge
performance and security
and our network offers
three times the throughput of other
cloud providers
third we remain
and were the very first
and only cloud provider
with a clear
multi-cloud strategy
we provide you with a consistent
developer experience
built an open source to write once and
deploy anywhere
many customers like plaid a financial
services leader
use antos
to deploy operate and manage
applications across multiple clouds
recently we introduced anthos for
virtual machines
standardizing the way that you manage
applications across both virtual
machines and containers
for multi-cloud data
bigquery omni
lets customers analyze data
across google cloud
aws
and azure
with it
johnson johnson for instance was able to
combine data in google cloud and aws s3
using bigquery omni without needing to
migrate data
customers also want to expand where they
use google cloud
whether in their private data centers or
out on the edge
for instance some workloads cannot move
to the public cloud entirely
due to the need for large amounts of
local data processing
extremely low latency or strict
regulations
to solve these challenges we're
announcing today
google distributed cloud
a portfolio of hardware and software
solutions that extend our infrastructure
to the edge
and even into your own data center
to tell you more about it
please welcome inez from our google
cloud distributed cloud team
thank you thomas
google distributed cloud is a set of
fully managed services running on google
managed hardware based on open apis and
built on antos it gives customers
greater deployment flexibility and
ensures more consistent operations
across hybrid and multi-cloud
environments more than any other cloud
provider
there are four deployment scenarios
depending on your specific needs
google's network edge this allows
customers to leverage over 140 network
edge locations around the world
operator ads this scenario is designed
to accommodate emerging services and
applications with a stringent latency
and reliability requirements for a
specific operator customer ads this
scenario supports customer owned edge
locations such as retail stores factory
floors or branch offices which require
localized compute and processing and
finally customer data centers this
deployment option is specific to
customer owned data centers and color
facilities
google distributed cloud also includes a
hosted mode to run sensitive workloads
and address data sovereignty security
and privacy requirements it does not
require connectivity to google cloud at
any time to manage infrastructure
services apis or tooling
you have the choice to manage it
yourself or host through a designated
trusted partner
back to you thomas
thank you ines
partners like hpe
dell cisco and netapp are key as we
deploy google distributed cloud globally
on best-in-class hardware
i'm pleased to announce the expansion of
our partnership with network appliance
in two important ways
first netapp is our primary partner
supporting google's distributed cloud
storage infrastructure
second for customers using google cloud
vmware engine
they now have preview access for netapp
cloud volumes
we are the only hyperscaler to provide
customers with this choice
deep partnerships with t-systems and
tolus
have also enabled us to address the
evolving
sovereignty requirements for cloud
technology in germany and france
the next question we hear
is how can we provide the best
environment to help employees create and
innovate together especially in a hybrid
workplace
you know hybrid is redefining how we all
work
making it less about where we work
but more about the quality of our
experience
studies estimate that more than 48 of
employees will work remotely post covet
google workspace is the best platform
for hybrid work
with simple
powerful
and secure tools to help people
communicate
and collaborate with one another no
matter where they are
we introduce smart canvas
to help content creators remove friction
from workflows
and enable teams to stay connected
outside of meetings to foster well-being
and reduce video call fatigue
we made communication and collaboration
completely seamless
for instance
users can easily present and collaborate
in meetings
create meeting notes from their calendar
present and meet directly from doc
sheets or slides and collaborate
directly from chat and spaces
we optimize collaboration from all
mobile devices
to provide great experiences for
frontline workers who make up 80 percent
of the global workforce
one of america's largest hospital
systems common spirit health
is advancing its mission during the
pandemic by making its front line
doctors and nurses productive with
google workspace
since hybrid work has removed the notion
of a physical location for work
google workspace created spaces
a unified digital location for work
today more than 3 billion users
move securely and seamlessly between
mail
chat audio video and now spaces
and you too
can choose among the over 5
300
public apps in our marketplace and you
can also add thousands of private apps
to enhance your workspace
now i want to step aside for just a
minute and tell you about a hidden
secret
in our portfolio products
app
appsheet
our no-code platform that makes it easy
for everyone
not just professional developers
to build amazing apps and workflows
for instance property managers at car 4
properties
used app sheet to build a mobile app
to log track and resolve problems with
headquarters
replacing a multi-step manual process
we're also partnering with citrix
because employees sometimes need access
to windows and mac os applications and
desktops
directly served from the cloud
we're expanding our partnership with
citrix today to deliver an integrated
desktop is a service solution
purpose built on google cloud
now customers ask us
do we know that our data systems and
users are secure
and how do we keep them secure
in the future
you know as more digital users access
more data from more locations
the risk of cyber security breaches is
exhilarating
by pioneering new approaches to security
google keeps more people safe online
than anyone else in the world
take for instance jetblue
it's keeping its system secure
protecting the data of all its travelers
and modernizing its security operations
using chronicle
to detect threats
across petabytes of security telemetry
eliminating data blind spots
commence bank
one of germany's largest banks
is using our new certificate authority
service
to verify machine
and workload identity improving security
simplifying operations eliminating
entire classes of threats
secure by default drives customers to
choose google cloud
first we've implemented zero trust at
the core of our services and our
operations enabling you to trust nothing
second we've built cloud scale threat
detection and response allowing you to
detect everything
and third we know it's not just about
tools we provide the advisory services
you need to transform security
operations
we keep customers safe with beyond corp
enterprise which enables zero trust
access for all your users today we're
expanding beyond corp to all your
applications
modern and legacy
web and desktop and even to production
environments
we keep customers safe
by eliminating software supply chain
vulnerabilities
over the past two decades
we pioneered an approach to secure our
own software supply chain
we are now making that technology
available
through the salsa open source framework
and as managed services on our cloud to
help you
secure your own software supply chain
we keep customers safe by integrating
chronicles threat detection capability
with our security command center
allowing you to respond faster to
potential risks
and we keep customers safe
by bringing our security expertise to
you
with our google cyber security action
team
a team of our leading security experts
who can help shape your security
transformation
from your very first implementation
through responding to a major incident
and engineering new solutions
as needs change
finally
we continue to expand our security
ecosystem with companies like fortinet
palo alto networks tallis and so many
more
today i'd like to welcome a new security
partner
cyber reason with whom we are
collaborating to deliver a new extended
detection and response offering that
will combine chronicles capability
with cyber reasons mallops engine
for faster easier threat detection and
response
our products
our new cyber security action team and
our partnerships
all make the world safer from cyber
threats
to talk more about how we help keep
each and every one of you secure
and how we're addressing some of the
most important challenges facing our
world
i'd like to invite sundar back
thank you
thank you
thomas security is top of mind for
businesses of all sizes
as well as the public sector
and despite the progress that has been
made in cyber security
large-scale breaches continue to make
headlines
that's why in august google announced
we'll invest 10 billion dollars over the
next five years to strengthen cyber
security
that includes expanding zero trust
programs
helping secure the software supply chain
and enhancing open source security
a new challenge is keeping collaboration
secure and private as we move to hybrid
work environments
to help we are introducing a new work
safer program
it provides the highest level of
security for your email
meetings messaging and more
and brings together google workspace
with tight and security keys beyond corp
and other secure technologies products
and partners
now every kind of organization and
business can access the same security
protections
that make work safer at google
security is an issue that affects us all
and this brings us to the last question
thomas posed
are we addressing the most important
challenges facing our world
climate change is one of the most
profound challenges we face
it'll take all of us working together to
solve it
sustainability has been a core value for
us for more than two decades
google has been carbon neutral since
2007
and we've matched our operations with
100 renewable energy over four
consecutive years
last year we set out to make our third
decade of climate action our biggest yet
that included a bold commitment to
operate on 24 7 carbon free energy
across our offices and data centers by
2030
and last week we announced new ways we
are helping one billion people make more
sustainable choices
when it comes to enterprises one of the
most important sustainability choices is
where to run your technology
idc predicts
cloud migrations over the next four
years
could reduce carbon emissions by over 1
billion metric tons
or the equivalent of removing 200
million cars off the road for a year
we are proud that google cloud is the
cleanest cloud in the industry
earlier this year we introduced a way
for customers
to choose the cleanest regions to run
their workloads
today we are expanding our portfolio of
solutions and partnerships to help
reduce your carbon footprint
first we have focused on giving you
greater transparency around carbon
emissions data
we are announcing carbon footprint a new
service to measure track and report the
gross carbon emissions associated with
your google cloud usage
having this data at your fingertips is
really important
and we know that many customers track
sustainability data in other places
that's why i'm happy to announce that
google cloud emission data will
integrate directly into salesforce
sustainability cloud
we also want to give you the tools to
act on the data
so today we are introducing a new tool
that will alert you when you have idle
workloads
and make recommendations to reduce
carbon emissions
it's all part of our goal to help make
your cloud transformation secure and
sustainable
and solve for what's next
so on behalf of thomas and myself
let me thank you once again for trusting
us to be a partner with you on this
journey and we hope you enjoy the next
three days
thank you
[Music]
you